hello world welcome to the CEO play st
vela from Spain so and see what he plays
in the English we should before it's a
good line play this the bottle Vinick
set up I think this is some quite a good
good setup for wide having good central
control black it quite often and puts
the bishop back on c5 okay another
Kingdom 95 here it's on d3 first I don't
know probably both us pretty comparable
comparable in terms of quality I'm
thinking okay so he is going back 95 or
this one I think I'll go with these
three and prepare for so f for now yeah
probably yes
hmm okay i want to gu g for anyway so
this might just help me gain some time
in general the idea of this c4e form
kind of center is to just totally block
the center especially on d5 white has
almost all of his pieces and okay gives
up on it I don't believe it let's take
this to block the center and then and
then play on the flank like I did here
with with f5 and so on it's not getting
a good grip in the center yet all
and takes Knight eggs you might get c5
and I don't really don't really want
that
maybe I should have taken a plate Bishop
e3 I mean okay this is not bad most
likely not but
see if I can t go e5 opening up the
diagonal and threatening e6
just try to take you for next maybe he
just goes back
you have two Soviet somewhat cautious
that with taking on a a down the bishop
is a very strong piece okay I probably
should take the snow then then grab it
with the night being over the board I
don't really feel that my king is in
danger try to I just want to tech now
myself Queens is seven or may just take
it to the cesium taking it
keeping it simple
Jeff threatening rookie 7
okay so if i take it all the easiest now
bring the King up
black resins a give me too many 10p I
thank you this night age five and then
the porn sec I don't think ultimately
works I think here this position should
be quite quite normal y equal ish but
this just gives me just time I want to
go at five anyway and yeah here at the
computer points out 95's being on button
maybe with a g4 is a good move yeah
Knight f6 now is probably called for but
you know he just lost time going to put
it here threatening g5 on ig3 just
drumming up an attack and and this just
does not work i think it's a big poem
for no particular compensation I could
have taken also on the form of it this
keeps a very substantial advantage okay
Bishop I a data computer justice
merciless grabbing everything but this
is as good as well check yeah and the
ending is it's just very simple to win
so don't jump no big experiments there
okay well thanks for watching